okay so this talk is going to be all
about streaming data technologies so I'm
going to talk a little bit about Kafka
and spark and Avro is anyone familiar
with Kafka in this room I just wanted to
get a shot oh great some copper users
here so I'm going to talk about it in
the context of building an astronomical
data stream this is public data it's
really exciting it's coming out of the
University in Washington and what we're
trying to do is we're trying to build an
ecosystem that is friendly enough so
that anyone can kind of jump in and take
a little bit of that of the Astronomy
data stream and build some apps and
tools and whatever they think is really
cool and inspiring and so I just have a
few pictures here one of my favorite
fountains this is from Chicago so I just
moved to Seattle recently from Chicago L
crown fountain and crown fountain is in
Chicago in Millennium Park and it's one
of these fountains that's been sort of
lauded for universal design in that it
has it's it's it's built up this
community around it of people who go
just as tourists your kids that are
playing the fountain it's got this like
big black granite reflecting pool and
these two towers and the towers show
these spaces of different community
members and at nighttime it's all lit up
and people take really great pictures
around it and so it's got this beautiful
universal design element delivering up
this fountain this stream of water and
so we're trying to do the same sort of
thing but with an astronomical data
stream and so this is just an inside
crown fountain and it does look really
simple on the outside and you think I'll
these are just two towers but when you
look at it in a little more detail it's
really complex and sort of the
architecture behind it because you're
putting all these lights in this system
and with its water streaming in and so
this is the South Tower of crown
fountain in detail and some of the
lighting system beneath there
I just wanted to show up because I I
love Chicago
so just a quick blurb about me I'm now a
scientist at the University of
Washington yeah before that I worked way
back when I got my PhD in astronomy and
I worked on star formation and outer
disks so there's a link to my thesis if
you're really interested I think no one
has read my thesis not even me so don't
bother but before after that I worked a
lot in a cloud computing at the
University of Chicago where I did some
reanalysis pipelines using storm and
Hadoop and accumulo for NASA satellite
imagery analysis and this system with
storm and Hadoop and accumulo was just
so hard to do reanalysis of data that
was streaming in and so when I moved to
learning about Kafka and Kafka and SPARC
together this is kind of really
reoriented me into a much more user
friendly system that I'm glad to talk to
you about today I also worked a little
bit on NOAA's moved to the cloud so a
few years ago with the Obama
administration there was a big emphasis
on having data that was open open gov
open data and making everything machine
readable open to the public and so I
worked a little bit on the NOAA big data
project when they're trying to move
about a petabyte of data to start out
with of climate data and weather data
meteorological data into the different
cloud systems Amazon Google IBM
Microsoft and something called the open
Commons consortium which is a consortium
of academic institutions and
universities and research labs that work
together to try and get data publicly
available and with services on top in
such a way that you can analyze the data
and move it around we want to be we want
the data to be portable so you're not
you know kind of stuck in one
environment or another and you can
really move it into cloud you can move
it out to your laptop you can move it
wherever you need to move it
and I did work a little bit on some API
based data services around something
called the open science data cloud when
I was at the University of Chicago which
was a petabyte scale system where we
provided a pool of data on different
kinds of medical data genomics data
weather data the satellite data natural
language processing data all kinds of
data and we develop API based data
services so you grab that data and you
can find what you need and you could
pull it to some basically like elastic
cloud virtual machines and do your
analysis right there and our petabytes
calcloud and so there's a great paper
that we wrote about this system which we
call a data Commons system it's called a
case for data Commons towards data
science as a service and that was
published last year in a special issue
on computing for data science and
engineering a little more about me blah
blah blah I'm a Cleveland native so I
like the Cavs but I'm a Chicago
transplant so I love to Cubs I also I
have my main Twitter at the running I'm
on the bottom footer here on my slides
but I also tweet my runs if you're if
you're a distance runner I run on run
average
I love eating pizza old-fashioned donuts
and old-fashioned drinks and beer and
recently if you saw the movie hidden
figures I was a awarded I'm I am a
hidden thing here guys I'm actually a
hidden figure from Pepsi's hidden figure
contest and you can watch my little
video about what Stan means to me as an
underrepresented woman and Sam on my
website the video is actually hidden for
some reason on YouTube so it's kind of
funny does not happen but you can find
it on my website there okay so this is a
slide that talks about streaming
technologies over the past 20 years and
so I starting off here in 1997 in August
1997 this is when Netflix started
so remember Netflix when it was only by
now so you had to like you to pick out
what you wanted to watch like a week in
advance which is hilarious now because I
remember there were times when I would
order a DVD from Netflix and then I
would order the same DVD like a month
later on accent because I forgot but I
already watched that DVD anyway so 20
years ago that was what Netflix was like
and then in the year 2000 Roy fielding
find rest in his CSIS rest standing for
representational state transfer I think
that's the stance for and then after
that things sort of exploded in the past
20 20 years and so on the bottom I have
the found the founding of all these
different companies that use a lot of
these streaming technologies that I'm
going to be talking about so LinkedIn in
2002 Facebook in 2004 YouTube 2005
Google had chat in 2005 Twitter and AWS
in 2006 Hadoop started out in 2006 also
github in 2008 whatsapp 2009 Pinterest
in 2010 Instagram also in 2010 and
snapchat in 2011 and so that covers a
lot of the ones that I use I think
there's more my little brothers would
put more stuff from 2012 to 2017 but
these are the main ones that I use here
and so what these companies have in
common is that they're using a lot of
this streaming big data tech and also
another thing that they have in common
is that they all contribute to your open
source so you can find a github for each
of these companies online with a lot of
open source tools around big data
streaming technologies and so what we're
trying to do in the astronomical
community where I do most of my work is
you know contribute to open source and
to use a lot of the big data tools that
are already out there and so along the
top access here
I'm going to give you a little bit of
information about what's going on in the
astronomical community in the last 20
years it has to do with big data and
streaming technology so in 2002 was the
foundation of something called the
International virtual Observatory
alliance so this is this big alliance of
different countries that come in comes
together and tries to figure out how can
we make astronomical data and tools
available to the public for anybody to
use across different countries and move
data around because the sky is you know
open to everybody
in 2004 the I VOA drafted something
called a virtual Observatory event or vo
event which is an alert system that
sends out an alert a message basically
whenever something interesting is being
detected on a telescope so it's
basically like a little Twitter feed for
for a telescope in 2010 and every about
10 years the astronomical community puts
together something called the decay toll
survey where we talk to the community
and figure out which are the large
projects that we want the government to
sort of put you know put put funding
towards which is the ones that we are
agree are important for lots of
different science projects and in 2010
the decadal survey recommended something
called the large synoptic survey
telescope which is the project that I
work on at the University of Washington
and then in 2011 there was an evolution
of the ivo ASBO event protocol there and
2014 the LSSC the large synoptic survey
telescope was started funding was
initiated by the National Science
Foundation and we expect that this
telescope it's under construction in
Chile right now I don't have any
pictures Google's and pictures that's
really it's really cool to see a new
telescope being constructed
but that's coming online in the next
five years or so but we're putting it
together all the data pipelines right
now and so you might not think of the
nice guy as something that is changing
all the time it looks like this thing
that you just look up at and it's there
you know every day it kind of looks
maybe slightly slightly different things
are in a different place but there are
things that are changing in the night
sky all the time and so that's why we're
building this basically Twitter feed
this news feed I should say not just
Twitter a news feed of updates from the
nice guy we want to know when supernovae
are going off we want to know an
asteroids are moving around we want to
know when there are clipping stars that
are making stars you know dip and
brightness and that kind of thing so
there's all kinds of things that are
happening in the night sky and we want
to set up the system such that we can
find out about it really fast within a
minute of this happening and being
detected on the large synoptic survey
telescope and we want to get the data
out to the public so they can do cool
things with it you can do whatever you
want you can you know write Knapp's it
turns this in all into music and you
could listen to the stream if you wanted
to or something like that or we we send
it out to other telescopes and robotic
telescopes that you could basically do
follow-up follow-up observations and get
spectra and do colors and figure out you
know you know what types of objects are
these and be able to better characterize
them by collecting more data and so this
is something that came out in the
Seattle Times just last week an article
about this new Institute at the
University of Washington called Dirac
which stands for di it's dir AC data
intensive research in astrophysics and
cosmology and so one of the things that
we're going to be doing with a large
synoptic survey telescope is to track
all these asteroids and build up a
database of asteroids such that we we
can predict their we can figure out
their orbits and we can predict whether
or not these
they're going to come in contact with
the earth and we want to be able to do
something about it
so in five years it says here a sky
scanning telescope that's the LSST
in Chile will begin hunting the heavens
for asteroids on a collision course with
the earth and scientists like myself at
the University of Washington are at the
forefront of work to spot them it's very
exciting right now to get involved with
astronomical data streams and so I just
had this quote here from Ghostbusters
which I love personally I liked the
university they gave us money and
facilities we didn't have to produce
anything you've never been out of
college you don't know what it's like
out there I worked in the private sector
they expect results so I'm not sure
about what it's like at Microsoft
but in academia we're expecting results
- we're expecting to do great things
with the LSST and we're going to put
together basically something that is a
valuable service this is a service to
the scientific community so that they
can take the data and they can do some
really great stuff with it
and so I have to talk about a little bit
more about Ghostbusters of course if I'm
talking about streaming data here and so
I think people at least in the
astronomical community and maybe not so
much at Microsoft but they're a little
bit afraid of streaming data and
streaming technology and that's because
streaming is a little bit it's for
complex right you don't do the
traditional you know batch work and when
you're building up a pipeline it's very
different and so people get really
scared about crossing streams you know
why because it would be bad right try to
imagine all life as you know it's
stopping instantaneously and every
molecule in your body exploding at the
speed of light it's not that bad is the
point it K it's a little bit
intimidating to get started but it
doesn't have to be that bad and so the
radical idea here is by the end of the
talk I'm going to hopefully give you
enough just a little bit of tooling so
that you can jump in and play with a
little ecosystem that's all open-source
and kind of get ready for astronomical
data streams because we're going to
we're going to cross the streams here so
you're going to endanger us you're going
to danger our client the nice lady who
paid us in advance before she became a
dog
not necessarily there's definitely a
very slim chance we'll survive I love
this plan
I'm excited to be part of it let's do it
this job is definitely not worth 11,500
a year in academia and so the idea here
is that we want to sort of change the
face of astronomy okay we want people
all types of people we want we want
universal design basically in
astronomical data streams we want you
know people here and Microsoft and
attending PI data to be able to
contribute we want a system that is
going to be really inclusive so that it
can be really innovative okay so I'll
give you my last slide here mid talk why
is this interesting astronomical data
streams are open to the public
awaiting creative use we've made some
tech choices with no hard requirements
on programming language and a low
barrier to entry or even ecosystem that
has wide support and use cases outside
of astronomy enhancing flexibility
usability sustainability what are we
looking at for transport we're looking
at Apache Kafka why because it's
scalable in cluster mode replicated by
design allows for stream rewind when we
you know make a mistake and it has many
use cases that we can share across our
systems for serialization of data we're
looking at Apache Avro for fast parsing
with structured messages in piping and
strictly enforced schemas but it allows
for schema evolution when the data needs
to change for filtering we're looking at
apache spark why because it has a direct
connection to Kafka and it has a very
batch like stream interface you can use
Python you can use some people like
queries and basically you can do batch
like analysis
using using spark and so it makes
streaming a lot less intimidating and
what can you do you can deploy all this
is all of what I'm showing you has been
doc rise so you can deploy this doctor
eyes Mach stream testbed with Casa here
on my github enjoy this alert stream a
link and I'm going to show the slide
again at the end you can check out a
sample of our Avro schema to see what
the data looks like that were using for
astronomy and you can check out this
website where I've made some docker eyes
Jupiter notebooks to do a complete
how-to that you can deploy alongside the
Kafka ecosystem testbed to do filtering
with sparks using a Kafka and Avro it's
called delay Oh
which is that Filipino word for a
strainer or winner where okay so this is
basically what the design of our system
looks like we are getting data from the
telescope and it's going to go through
we have new data that's collected every
39 seconds on the LSST it's going to run
through our pipelines we're going to do
some detection algorithms on on our
images to find new sources things that
have changed things that have moved at
some level about five Sigma I think it's
five Sigma level and then we're going to
have a distribution hub which basically
sends out these alert streams to these
community brokers so there are brokers
these largest large-ish medium-sized
collaborations that are going to be
taking the full stream of alerts and
then sending them out to subscribers on
the other end so you as an individual
user you could subscribe to any of these
community brokers which are doing things
like adding value they're doing
characterization they're going to say
this is a supernova so you can subscribe
to these supernovas if you want them or
if you wanted to you could get your
friends together and you could say hey I
would like to put together a candy
d broker gives me this full stream of
alerts and will say sure here you go
take all the data that you want and you
can go ahead and you can do that so you
guys could build up and test your
algorithms on this public data stream so
what we're trying to do here is we're
sending out the alert stream to these
community brokers we're also going to
have this alert oh it doesn't show up
very well there's black here that's
supposed to show you the flow anyway it
goes down you get the point it's a
string it's going to we're also going to
have an alert database so this is why
we're using Kafka because it's really
nice to send all the same data to the
community brokers and sync it up with
the alert database so we can keep track
of all the data that we're sending out
it's very important this is scientific
data we want to do reproducibility right
we're really concerned about that kind
of thing
and want to keep all these things in
sync we don't want to lose many data
we're also sending out images little
postage stamps cutouts we call them
postage stamps of what these 5 Sigma
detections look like they could be you
know completely round because maybe
they're star-like objects or they could
be extended sources they could you know
if they're moving objects or whatever
asteroids and that kind of thing so you
could do image characterization if you
wanted on the postage stamps and then so
the end users are down there and we
wanted to even easily enough that my dog
tweek I also had a dachshund by the way
tweek Kanna you know listen to the
stream if she wants to while she's
barking and so these are the large alert
streams that are open to the public
there's going to be one that's very
similar that I'm also working on at the
University of Washington called the wiki
transient facility and that's coming
online next year actually so if you want
to practice you could subscribe to that
public data stream we're going to have
about 1,000 alerts per visit so this is
1,000 objects every 45 seconds for VTS
the wiki transient facility in 10,000
every 39 seconds for the LSST
which means that there will be 1 million
alerts per night from ziti
or 10 million from LSST each the size of
each alert is going to be 20 kilobytes
for ztf 50 to 150 kilobytes for the LSS
key and so that means our nightly data
stream ends up being on 20 to 40
gigabytes for ztf or about a terabyte at
night this is just the alert data not
even the image data this is just the
alerts that basically the text that
that's being sent out and the numbers
that characterize what the alert looks
like and the little postage stamps Oh
terabyte and night from the LSST this is
going to be very big for for for
astronomy and if you look at a database
of all of the vo events to date this is
the one database that we really have
from April 2014 to yesterday there have
only been one point six million at the
field event database place which means
there's about one per minute and so
we're going from one per minute to one
thousand every 45 seconds next year and
ten thousand every thirty nine seconds
in 2020 so it's going to be big so we
would welcome help there's a lot of cool
things that can be done here and so okay
let's dig a little bit deeper into the
ecosystem and how it works and why we
made these choices so again I said
Apache cough cough has scalability
replication allowing for stream rewind
is very important Apache Avro structured
messages and schemas and it allows us to
send out these postage stamps you can
actually embed images in a row data
format and then we do all our filtering
or planning to do our filtering with
Apache spark and so how does Apache
kafka work it basically works like a
distributed log system or a messaging
queue and they've sort of rebranded and
reinvented themselves recently as a
distributed streaming platform and so
it's a strongly ordered basically
pub/sub
streaming platform where you have these
messages that and every message has an
offset and you basically have producers
that write to these logs and consumers
keep track of an assistant keeps track
of where the consumer is by keeping
track of the offset where it is in the
log and this way way you don't have to
have multiple streams per consumer so it
scales really well when you add multiple
consumers which is what we want we don't
want to have to have one copy of the
stream per consumer this is a terabyte
of night that we have to deliver to the
public it's highly scalable if used in
production in LinkedIn
Netflix and Microsoft I forgot I put
that on the side but a piece here and
Microsoft it has great clients and
connectors including Python which I love
I love Python so it's got good usability
and so there's a little diagram from the
Costco website of a kafka cluster it's
got databases that you can connect apps
that you can connect it's really pretty
simple to get going basically on a kafka
system so here is what our little
streaming testbed looks like if you go
to alert stream you'll get a doctors
compose file for Kafka and zookeeper so
we can just spin up the whole system
using docker compose it configures a
connection to the Costco broker and sets
the stream topic so this is what you do
you just do from the alert stream import
alert producer this is if you want to
mock a stream of alerts that's sent to
Kafka so an alert producer you set the
topic the name of the topic you say this
is my alert stream and the schema for
the alerts which is just a JSON schema
and I'll show you an example schema and
then it takes the dictionary that
follows at schema and you can turn Avro
encoding on or off maybe you just want
to use the dict
and send the messages like that you
don't want the algorithm coding so you
can turn it on or off and here this will
just set you up so you have your Kafka
system
and it has a stream of alerts all set
and this will give you the actual LSS G
data you can also use template consumers
to see the alerts that you sent to the
Kafka Booker so again from LSST alert
stream you can see oh that's wrong it
should be alert consumer there and from
when you set up your stream reader you
just give it also the topic that you
want to subscribe to the name of the
stream so you would say I want to listen
to my alert stream and you can give it a
schema it can be different actually than
the one that you you produce too and
I'll show you an example of that and
then you just pull the stream reader and
if it has a message then we say print
the message if not keep going until you
get a message and you can do also turn
stamp collection the collection of the
images maybe you don't care about the
images you can turn that on or off too
and then there's also a script script
that just monitors the stream to see how
many messages there are so who are you
familiar with Apache Avro or the people
that use Avro ok great there's a few
people in the room that use Avro after
all is really nice because it applies
structure to your data that it allows
you to have it outside of a database
basically so here is just a a a a
diagram from data bricks actually where
you know unstructured data with your
text files and your CSV s it's more
flexible you can put whatever you want
in there then you have semi structured
data like XML or JSON which allows you a
little bit of a structure and you have
headers and keys and that kind of thing
and then you can go to much more
structured data like if you use a sequel
database or if you use Avro or something
that park' where you get much more
efficient storage and performance
because you can put in typing in your
data and the nice thing about Avro and
park' is that you don't have to have a
database so you can really do bulk
transport of large sets of data really
easily and another reason why we use
Avro is because the messages in cost
they they suggest cause confluent is the
startup company that's really taking
care of Kafka in the open source world
they suggest using Avro for their
messages and it's been pretty nice to
work with and so what you do is you
define a schema with JSON and then you
can have dynamic typing and strict
adherence to the types that you could
say this is a byte stream for an image
and this is you know a flow and this is
long this is a string and it's used in
production is also used in science so we
use it in astronomy but also that you
don't to know mix world also uses Avro
so it's good enough for cancer data so
this is what a sample schema looks like
for example you have a namespace here
and you have a type this is a record
type of data and for users and so you
have three fields here you just have the
name which is a string you have a
favorite number which is an int or could
be null and it gives us a favorite color
which could be a string or a null and so
then you have your data which is
separate and kind of like wrap up the
data and schema and so your name could
be been favorite color is red and your
favorite number this is a Python little
Python code so it could be a random
integer from there to 10 there so this
is just an example of data formatting
Avro and so with the lssj and ztf we're
using the same sort of schema where we
basically have an alert ID which is a
long and you can add some documentation
descriptions in there then we have also
candidate IDs because we have we want to
map all these alerts to specific objects
and then you can also include previous
previous detection zazz arrays of
variable length and then we can put out
the cut out images in there as well
and so this is just showing you how you
take your schema for the stamps for
example so this is a stamp record again
and we have two fields just the file
name and then your stamped file name
which is a string and your stamp data
which is bytes and then in Python you
just open up a file and you read it read
it as binary and then you have your
stamped data and then you can just pop
it in there and you can send out image
data as or any file actually you can put
it into your Avro data and send it off
and alerts and this is showing you some
of the flexibility that you get with a
row here for example the top this could
be a long string not string along
Bunch's data basically and there might
be some fields that you don't really
care about but what you can do is you
can set a schema that says okay I just
want the source ID the time the filter
the location called RA and Dec in
astronomy and a signal-to-noise ratio
and just give me I'm going to set that
schema and just give me that data that's
all I want and then at the bottom shows
you that's the data that you get so you
just take your schema and you can cut
out some fields and then you can get the
data that you want there so this is a
data flow that we're looking at
basically where we have a Kostka cluster
that's going to send out the full stream
of alerts to filter service and then
send many streams possibly have filtered
alerts back to Kafka and the filter
service will do something with possibly
where you take the schema and you can
cut down the columns basically the data
that you want and we could take queries
basically in SPARC or Python and that
will cut the records that you want and
then take the filtered alerts and then
send them out to these community brokers
and so you can get you know like a
broker for supernova broker for
eclipsing stars a broker for asteroids
etc and so one of the things that we
want to think about in terms of what
data is available in
- the in this alert stream system is
what sets the look-back time for bash
versus stream and you're making a query
are you going to the database the record
or are you going to this like the
Twitter stream basically add new alerts
and so you want to think about that
because we're going to have 10,000 per
second
right inverse possibly and so when you
make a query how are you figuring out
like how do you know that you've got all
the ones that you asked for if your
request times basically you know is at
the same level as as the is a data
stream that's coming in and so we really
want batch and stream to sort of look
the same way you want to be able to use
batch functionality in such a way that
you can interact with databases and like
sequel like queries in the same way that
you can interact with the alert stream
and that's why we're looking at spark
and spark streaming specifically to pull
from this alert stream and this is just
a comparison of some other streaming
systems like I've worked with apache
storm for example and it doesn't
integrate with batch as well and so
patchy spark and we've heard a lot about
spark is really nice because it does
give you this flexibility in ecosystems
in the in the in the tools that I'm
providing in the ecosystem and github
everything is docker eyes so you can
just deploy a docker eyes Jupiter
notebook that does have spark and the
docker container for you and so it has
all the tools that you need right there
and so you can employ it deploy it in
docker also ec2 OpenStack and you can
take data sources from a number of
places directly for example Hadoop my
sequel you can read Parque and you can
read from Kafka which is really nice
you can also read directly Avro data
from spark so that's really nice that we
can interact with basically large
storage systems of Avro alerts so we can
build up our database as basically a
profiles and you can search and query
over those files of alerts and find for
example everything in this part of the
sky where you're going to be looking at
tonight and you want to know what's
interesting up in that part of the sky
you can search over the storage of files
and you can search over the alert stream
in the exact same way and so the way
that spark works in the streaming system
is it's basically taking in the data
stream and every new alert basically is
going to be sort of like a new row in
its unbounded table and so here is an
example of the ecosystem component
called vallejo which is a Filipino word
meaning a rice winnower winner where was
already taken in Python so I had to be a
little bit more creative bôla' is what
you see to win a rice or it's like a
food serving tray so this is what we're
using to filter or a Costco alert stream
so what you can do you just set up the
connection using PI spark streaming
Koska and you create this direct stream
for example this one is called my stream
you point it to your caucus server you
could say Auto offset to the smallest so
if you lose connection you go back to
the beginning what's available and then
you give yourself a group ID so you can
add you can add more nodes to your spark
cluster if you want to and then you just
have this alert this map function where
I take every alert and I just say I want
the ID for this alert I'm going to throw
away all the data and all you have to do
is you define a little function that
says return alert alert ID and there you
go you can just map all of the alert
streams really really easy
so then at the end you apply the map
function and then you just print it out
and you start your spark streaming
context this works in Jupiter and
notebook in the doc rice container with
the eco system so you can you can go
ahead and play with it there this is
just basically the same kind of
demonstration here but we're filtering
on right ascension which is one of the
you know location configurations for
first in astronomy so it's like okay we
want to look at every object in the
alert stream that has a right ascension
greater than 350 so what we're going to
do is you can set up your spark stream
in connection to Kafka you can create
the stream that that spark is going to
to use and then you can apply the filter
and then you can start the streaming
connection there and then it just prints
to be it prints to the screen so that's
basically all I wanted to say if you
wanted to go online you can more than
welcome to sort of explore the ecosystem
and you'll be hearing more about the
data intensive research in astrophysics
and cosmology Institute as the LSST
comes online Thanks Thank You Maria this
is I find this really exciting it's
there's so much great daughter out there
that's really hard to get hold of and to
be able to get like a really high volume
stream of data coming out that's free to
access is incredible and I hope we get
to see more of it so this is really
exciting I've had one question come in
through Twitter and again we're taking
questions through Twitter by priority if
you're in the room then we'll go to the
room if we need to I've had one come in
how do you how do you are you sharing
the schemas for this stream with
schirmer's the schemas will be available
on github so they're on this this slide
actually I have a
a sample of the alert stream we're also
sharing them on the LSST and the Rickey
transient facilities github and as they
evolve they'll they'll still be publicly
available so that you can use them as a
template and kind of cut down what you
want to get out of the stream so it's
all publicly available have you thought
about or considered the possibility if
the schema has to change in the future
yes we are thinking about that because
the schema is already changing as we're
trying to figure out what data that
we're going to put in we will have a
likely set up multiple streams that come
out of Kafka and so you might have
version 1 or version 2 etc as we go
through and figure out what is the most
useful data that people are going to to
use Kafka also I believe has a schema
like system where they also help keep
track and you can grab new schemas and
so we're going to definitely look at
that and if there are people that use
that in the room I'm definitely
interested in connecting with you if
here if you are interested also in that
kind of stuff
and we've definitely got a lot of smart
people in the room who are going to be
able to use this data for wonderful and
amazing things what kind of ideas have
you had that people might use this data
for I think there's obviously
astronomers are going to be interested
to know when things are happening but
what about the non astronomers in the
room what fun can we have here I think
there is so one of the issues that we
have in astronomy is that we know what
to look for for a lot of things like
supernovae and for moving objects but
there is a real possibility and I mean
we will see things that we haven't seen
before and so that is a great way where
people can sort of get involved looking
sort of like it anomaly detection and
just interesting object detection and so
and if you have any sort of real
interest maybe not in the astronomical
stream component but in quality of
service as you know as the telescope
survey it's going to be a ten year
survey and you know we might have issues
with some of this
CDs or something and so you can
definitely help us out with quality
insuring science quality and all of our
data right we have just lost the
projector screen unfortunately but what
so what's the best way for someone to
get involved in this yeah so we have a
Twitter stream the LSST has a Twitter
stream and you can follow along there at
LSST and at LSST EPO education and
public outreach office there's also a
forum called community community LSST
org and there's a lot of there's a lot
of interaction and discussion that
happens on community and you can find
out about all of our conferences which
are open to the public as well so thanks
for that question right thank the slang
barrier again
[Applause]